the formula here and what it does is it
finds the distance between two points
now if the points are just horizontal
you know you can just count the number
of spaces or if they're vertical you
could just count the number of spaces
but when it's on a diagonal like this
the distance formula really comes in
handy when you look at these subscripts
here
see the two and the one that's referring
to point number two so see x2 y2 this is
like a second point and x1 y1 that's
referring to point number one okay
so what we're doing is we're subtracting
the x-coordinates okay and squaring and
then we're subtracting the y-coordinates
and squaring and then we add those
together and we take the square root and
that'll give us the distance between the
two points okay so let's do some
examples so like say for example we have
the points four six and seven ten so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take X minus X so 7 minus 4 quantity
squared plus y minus y 10 minus 6 the
quantity squared add those together and
take the square root and that's going to
give us the distance so this is three
squared plus four squared okay which is
nine plus sixteen that's the square root
of 25 which equals five so the distance
between these two points will be five